where she's seen that has promised to
stop the boats is that even possible
very difficult to say it if it will be
possible but I agree that it's a wider
problem it's not only what is happening
in the channel
I think we have to look at migration
routes from Libya from Turkey from
Tunisia from many other countries we
have climate change which is producing
more refugees
so in the end I think what we will need
is a stronger international cooperation
to cope with this problem I just want to
have a look at some figures if I may
because I think if we look at the
graphic that I'm about to show you
Germany is clearly more Asylum Seekers
than the UK you can see the UK they're
in red this is the number of Asylum
applications for a hundred thousand
people uh Germany all the way up there
with 178 the UK down at 87. how much of
an issue is in Germany it is an issue
because we have more than one million
refugees who came from Ukraine so that
is already a heavy burden plus all the
others from Syria Iraq Afghanistan so we
are also in a debate about what to do
and how to distribute the burden but the
difference is that in Germany Asylum and
to claim Asylum is a constitutional
right and so everybody who comes legally
or illegally can claim Asylum and will
be listened to that's interesting
because obviously UK there's a very
clear distinction between people who
come through the legal routes for the
schemes with Ukraine for example and
people who enter on small boats many
people think the only way to actually
stop the boats is to assign a returns
agreement so that they can be sent back
to France but obviously that would mean
not signing a returns agreement with
France but with the EU do you think
that's something that the EU would
consider I'm not sure that you will
consider that but the better way I think
is to talk to countries of origin like
Albania because in Germany we also I
think only accept less than one percent
of albanians as real Asylum Seekers the
majority comes for economic reasons so
we have an agreement to return them to
their country of origin and I think this
is the way to go but let me really
clearly say Sophie that for us I think
the important thing is to respect
international law and that means the the
Geneva Refugee convention and the
European convention for human rights do
you think that the UK is respecting
international law then I've seen that
the Prime Minister made a statement at
the French British Summit where he
clearly stated that the United Kingdom
is going to respect international law
okay
um let's move on to Ukraine uh shall we
um the international criminal court has
issued an arrest warrant for Vladimir
Putin is that news that you welcome it's
definitely a very important moment for
international law for the international
criminal justice because it means really
accountability at the highest level
and so yes we welcome it and on Monday
we are going to have here in London a
conference Dominic Rapp has invited
Justice ministers from all over Europe
to discuss how we can strengthen the
work of the international criminal court
and I think it sends a very clear signal
also to everybody in Russia about what
can happen if they are part of crimes
against humanity do you think it sends
an important message to other global
leaders as well Vladimir Putin's due to
be meeting the Chinese president for
example do you think it will perhaps
send a bit of a signal to countries who
are perhaps not recognizing Putin's
crimes yes definitely and we have
123 countries who are part of the
international criminal court
and for all of them it will always be a
question can you still talk and receive
somebody like Putin and there is an
International arrest warrant so all of
that will limit Putin's possibilities
but Sophie let me also say that we have
to look also at the political Fallout of
that because what does it mean
will this mean that Russia's position on
the war will harden even more so there
are many many implications which need to
be taken into account and you think
there is a risk of that there is a risk
of that but at the same time I think
within the Putin Administration many
people will have now second thoughts
about their participation in this in
this crime of aggression in this womb
and now let's talk a bit about weapons
because Poland and Slovakia have decided
to send fighter jets to Ukraine do you
think Germany would consider doing that
in the future
um we don't have the f-16s Ukraine has
requested but nevertheless I think it's
a very important move by Poland and
Slovakia to do that we are currently
putting together a big International
Alliance to send the leopard tanks so we
are building up more than two battalions
tank battalions training has just
finished and I would expect the leopard
to arrive as soon as possible in Ukraine
Germany for obvious historical reasons
has a reluctance to send armaments to
keep dragged into conflicts how much of
a journey would you say that your
country has been on in the last year
with a war in Ukraine yeah it was a
fundamental change of our policy not
only on arms delivery but also towards
Russia
but I mean the fact that we are now
leading this coalition to send a large
amount of Tanks to maintain them to
procure the artillery the ammunition the
logistics I think all of that shows that
Germany is now really in a leading
position on supporting Ukraine on the
military side we are more or less at the
same level as the United Kingdom but if
you take everything together we are I
would say the second support of Ukraine
internationally
do you think you're a bit slow Off the
Mark initially
was it more difficult discussion in
Germany that's something very clearly
and we had
um to totally restructure our Russia
policy that's why it took a little bit
longer than in other countries and is
that because of the energy dependence on
Russia in particular no I think it had
more to do with the historic
relationship which would not forget that
the Soviet Union was part of achieving
German reunification that we all tried
to build up
a system in Europe where we could
include Russia in a in a in an
International Security architecture and
regrettably that has failed now we have
to learn our lessons from them it's
interesting to hey talk about that um so
openly uh now I want to talk a bit about
brexit because of course we have these
votes in the House of Commons on
Wednesday on the Winds of framework
what is your message to conservative MPS
to dup MPS units to MPS from Northern
Ireland who might be looking at this and
thinking I can't support this yeah I I
think it's a very good compromise
that has been worked out quietly over
four months between the European
commission and the British government
uh it's a compromise like always it
preserves The Good Friday agreement it
preserves East-West trade it means that
that the border between the Republic of
Ireland and Northern Ireland can stay
open so I think it achieves all the main
objectives and what I hear very often
from business people in Northern Ireland
is what they need is predictability and
stability and I think the Winds of
rainbow can achieve that I guess they're
from the unionist perspective in
Northern Ireland
their priority is being treated like the
rest of the UK so that they are treated
in exactly the same way as Glasgow as
Nottingham as London and for them that
doesn't achieve it do you think that
people in the EU really understand the
depth of feeling from the DP and others
yes I think we we do that and the
commission has reached out I myself have
met several times Jeffrey Donaldson
obviously we understand the
sensitivities of the dup and other
unionists but at the same time I think
we need a compromise which allows us to
have the necessary confidence in the
agreement and I think this has been
achieved so Sophie let me say that we
are very confident not only that there
will be an overwhelming majority
in the House of Commons but also that
this is an agreement where we can build
on to strengthen the relationship
between the United Kingdom and the
European Union how different has it been
for the EU and for Germany and others
dealing with Rishi sunak as opposed to
Boris Johnson and this trust
I think that with prime minister sunak
and especially the relationship he has
developed with the president of the
European commission Ms fonderlein is a
relationship of trust and this is
something we can build on so we have
full confidence that the British
government is really going to implement
what was agreed and as we know that was
not the case with Boris Johnson how
would you describe the relationship with
Boris Johnson
I would say that the relationship was
really at a at a very low point there
was no trust that things that are agreed
will be implemented and this is
absolutely different now so I think we
can look into a brighter future in the
relationship between the United Kingdom
and the European Union okay thank you
very much for coming on the program
thank you Sophie